spinal fusion is performed on the
spine to fuse two or more vertebrae together
using surgical devices and
bone graft material
the spine is made up of a series of
interconnected bones called
vertebrae that extend from the base
of the skull to the coccyx
each vertebra connects with  the one that is
up and down through the
facet joints allowing
it to move relative to
each other between each vertebrae i.e. there is
a shock absorbing intervertebral disc
the facet joints and
intervertebral discs work together
to allow movement of the
back and neck
protected within the spinal column
is the spinal cord which
connects the brain to the rest of the
body spinal nerves come from the
spinal cord at regular intervals your
doctor may recommend a
spinal fusion if you have any of the
following conditions a
fractured vertebra  excessive movement between
vertebrae causing instability and
pain
spondylus is a degenerative arthritic condition
that can cause loss
of normal spinal structure and function
or spondylolisthesis a condition
in which one vertebra slips
forward relative to the vertebra
next to it other conditions  that
may require surgery are
osteoarthritis of the
facet ary joints a spinal deformity such as
scoliosis kyphosis
or a bulging or herniated disc that
may put pressure on the
outgoing spinal nerve
spinal fusion aims to
eliminate motion between the
affected vertebrae by making the
spine  stability and
less pain before the
procedure an
IV will be placed a catheter may be placed
in your bladder to drain
urine spinal functions are
performed under general anesthesia which
means you will be asleep
for the duration of the
operation  will insert a  breathing tube through
your mouth into your windpipe to help you
breathe during the procedure
if your surgeon is using your own
bone for the fusion he or she will make an
incision over your hip and remove a
bone graft
if your bone graft comes from another
donor it will be  removed prior to your
procedure
if you are having an
open lumbar spine procedure in your
lower back you will lie on your
stomach and your surgeon will make an incision
directly over your spine
if you are having
cervical spine surgery in your  the neck your
surgeon will usually access
this area from the front in
some cases a spinal fusion can
be done using a
newer, less
invasive laparoscopic technique instead of making one or two
large incisions a laparoscopic spinal fusion
requires several
small incisions  key
through which is inserted into the laparoscope
and special surgical instruments
using a high speed drill and
other instruments your surgeon will remove
the disc between the two
vertebral bodies to be joined
then your surgeon will insert the
bone graft into the space between these two
vertebrae
the doctor will possibly place a
plate and screws over the graft to
hold the vertebrae together  together until
they fuse into a single bone to finish
the procedure your surgeon will
incise the deep tissue and skin
with stitches many surgeons
will also place one or more drains
under the skin that will remain in place
for a few days after surgery
procedure
you will be moved to a
recovery area for monitoring
the bladder catheter may remain
in place for several days
you may not be able to eat for a day or two
after surgery and will receive
fluids food through an IV
it is expected that  there is pain for the
first few days after surgery and
you will be given  medications to
control it